the brilliance of many of these idea
pathogens
is that it can penetrate all of your
education
and knowledge now of course science is
provisional and that what we thought was
true
300 years ago might get updated science
is autocorrective so it's not
a revealed truth and we're done might
drop but it is that we do think that
there are things to be discovered so
postmodernism is is the granddaddy of
idea pathogens for that reason
one instantiation of six degrees of
focusality
is six degrees of nom chomsky so i give
you a malady around the world and you
have to link it to the u.s
military industrial complex in six or
fewer steps
there you go that's why the spies don't
chomsky because he's a buffoon
he did something great with his
universal grammar he should have stuck
to that
but then when you become the proverbial
to every and i have these quotes in the
book you know i'm paraphrasing now
to the one who's holding the the hammer
the world looks like it's made of nails
that's exactly what norm chomsky has
been doing for 40 years
every single thing is associated to the
us
he you know he's never met a dictator
that he doesn't love he hasn't
so he he suffers from regrettably a lack
of epistemic
humility you mentioned earlier when you
went to give a talk and someone asked
you about global warming
and you said well you know i don't know
enough about global well guess what i'm
exactly like you if you ask me about
global warming
so you know what i i just don't know
enough about it if you ask me about
whether the pros and cons of
legalization of marijuana i just don't
know enough about it
but if you ask me about things
that as i explained in chapter seven
i've already built the normological
network of cumulative evidence for it
then i'm coming at you with all of the
swagger
that my tsunami of evidence allows me to
walk with
in other words i know what i know and i
know what i don't know
noam chomsky doesn't know what he
doesn't know he knows
about everything and it's always due to
the us military-industrial complex and
the rest of his [ __ ] so that's why i
have an aversion to him
because he doesn't exude for me the type
of
in other words i could be completely
wrong but i have a sense when i see
someone
whether they are somebody that i would
like to hang out with whether they're
cool
and he doesn't strike me like he's that
guy because he's the type of guy who's
going to be pontificating
over me all evening and i don't like
these kinds of fellows
when you think about establishing uh
your dream utopian university sad
university i want to ask you
first of all what courses would you make
mandatory for
purely intellectual uh uh broadening of
the human mind of a young person's mind
what would you make on the core
curriculum of sad university
a great question uh probably how to
think right and so maybe i can go to to
that
section in the book and answering your
question so in chapter seven
uh it's i discuss how to seek truth and
i argue that
you one of the most powerful tools that
i can think of epistemologically in
establishing the veracity of a position
is to build what i call normalogical
networks of cumulative evidence and so
let me
draw a parallel with the original
granddaddy of such
a process so charles darwin you know
that white supremacist
uh charles darwin had
in developing his theory of uh theory of
evolution natural selection
he didn't collect data from 30
undergrads in
ohio state university and then say
goodnight everybody i've proven my
theory
over almost three decades he assiduously
collected data
from an extraordinarily different
distinct lines of evidence from geology
from paleontology from ecology from
biodiversity from animal husbandry
from comparative morphology which when
you put it all together
it it it completed the puzzle right
and so put that now in a modern context
i argue that what charles darwin did
150 years ago is how we need to
address questions about the veracity of
a position
and let me draw an example which i
discussed in the book
so if i'm trying to convince you brian
that
toy preferences are not socially
constructed
in other words it's not mommy and daddy
who are sexist pigs who tell
little johnny to play with the blue
truck and little linda to play with the
pink doll
it's not about that there are some
biological reasons why
there is a sex specificity of toys what
are the types of distinct lines of
evidence i can get
in proving my point to you so this is
not a literature review
literature review is actually a lot more
restrained in its epistemological power
it's not a meta-analysis it's much
bigger than that it is saying
what is all of the possible universal
data from
every imaginable source across time
periods
across cultures across disciplines
across frameworks that would prove my
position so
i won't build you the whole neurological
network but i'll give you a few so that
you can get a sense well
i could take children who are in the
pre-socialization stage of their
cognitive
development meaning that they they're
too young to have been socialized
and i could show you that they already
exhibit that sex specificity of toy
preferences
that's already putting a a death blow to
the social construction lower limit on
it right
exactly but i'm going to keep going i
could go to comparative psychology
and look at other animals as i mentioned
earlier verve monkeys rhesus monkeys and
chimpanzees
and show you that their infants exhibit
that sex specificity
well now i've shown you from
developmental psychology from
comparative psychology but i'm not done
yet
i could get you data from pediatric
endocrinology what does that mean
so little girls who suffer from
congenital adrenal hyperplasia this is a
endocrinological disorder that
masculinizes the behavior and morphology
of little girls
i could take these little girls and show
you that if they suffer from this
disorder
their toy preferences are reversed they
become like those of boys
i could look at data from several
thousand years ago
funerary monuments from ancient greece
where they
have depictions of boys and girls and i
can show you that they depict them
playing with the same types of toys that
we're playing with today so
bit by bit through history through time
periods through culture
i could dismantle the possibility of
your position
so what i would do to answer your
original question
is before teaching people content
what is the capital of france i would
teach them
how to think because then that univ that
universal epistemological key
i could use it in any landscape you want
me to use it
would you teach chomsky would you teach
zinn what
how would you even as a cautionary
example yeah i mean it's for the same
reason by the way that i would teach
religion so
even though i'm not i might not be a
very religious person there
are as a historical document as
a literary document as a moral document
and at times
immoral document a lot of people think
that oftentimes when i critique
some of the idea pathogens that come out
of the humanities and the social
sciences
i'm denigrating those not at all
you can study uh chaucer and shakespeare
in a very serious way
you could study uh the philosophy of
aesthetics in a very beautiful and
so it's not as though oh you're a
physicist or you're a real thinker
or you're a sociologist you must have
failed in physics
not at all i don't have a natural
hierarchy but what i'm saying though is
always be committed to reason to logic
not necessarily always a scientific
method because you can't necessarily
study chaucer
using the scientific method but you
can't be decoupled
from our reasoning faculties that's all
i'm saying
you